yet I might be generating static
electricity with all my movement
trying you can you make it go faster
Oh plotting against it in high school
damn shame good news bad news good news
we got chica here and you're with me so
that's pretty cool
bad news is we're on the way to Cracker
Barrel but that would normally be good
news but we're supposed to get there in
three hours in 44 minutes estimated to
get in there 10:57 Cracker Barrel in Las
Vegas closes at 10:00 p.m. which is
awfully generous for what we're trying
to do but I'm hoping because it's rush
hour right now it's currently 708 which
means that if we're if we're booking it
I'll get there traffic and we really
push this bad boy to the best of its
abilities the barrel is gonna be
barreling down the highway and we're
gonna get the Cracker Barrel just in
time for the barrel to get some barrel
and meat chicken and dumplings in me I'm
not gonna prepare I'm not gonna be in
seatbelts all safe good chica you ready
why didn't you wake up on time I know it
wasn't me no I didn't know that that was
not me I woke up in plenty of time to do
whatever I was doing that you don't need
to know about lately illegal maneuvers
are logical when you are rushing to
Cracker Barrel nobody can stop you from
getting what you want which is delicious
chicken and dumplings in your butt after
you've put it in your mouth and then you
digest it
that's how poops made how fast can you
go
clock is ticking
oh come on my life has mostly been a
rush just ever since I started doing
YouTube but now that I'm kind of like
just adventuring on the van I don't know
things that felt more free it's been
pretty good you know we did that awesome
video project we did a lot of other
things and frankly this has been nice to
be able to get out and go around even
though now the stress that I put it
myself as a stress that is self-imposed
even though there's something void
before but either way it's good to get
out and it's good to be having it having
my objectives that you only set for
yourself but I'm only going fifty hoping
maybe maybe Las Vegas is in a different
like time zone than where we are right
now and if that's true then we cross
over into the barrier to Nevada we'll be
able to get into a different in the past
and then we'll have two minutes which is
more than enough time than I need to
cram them chicken and dumplings down my
gullet and have a good meal in that ride
buffs Gingka can do in one minute I
don't know I just been able to hang out
with my friends more been able to think
about like just the creative behind the
Y of her videos you know
the why of making things and it's
something that I don't often get to talk
about even in the videos that sell so
it's nice to be able to talk to you
about it you know person to person
oh you guys knack there what you get oh
that's cool
sixty
[Music]
god that's that ah ah God Oh
made a slight error but hey GPS has
already compensated for it we're still
on target we're two minutes two minute
delay that's not that bad we missed an
exit
that's fine happens to anybody could it
happen to anybody why does it only
happen when I'm in a hurry I need my
jumps no it's okay I appreciate it good
news we're making good time
we're already estimated to be there 1058
so judging by the trajectory of the
amount of time we're saving over the
period of with which we're going we
should get there just in time but I
wanted to talk about something else
before I get laid the danger is probably
so I've been asking more thoughts about
live-streaming you know
I I just feel like I want a live stream
or and and nothing I'm sick of Let's
Plays that's not what it is I love
gaming gaming has been a big part of my
life since I was a kid I want to do more
of it like I want a live stream for a
few hours in every single day
I don't know what you think of that for
you can let me know
it's wanna play games and have that
feeling and be
in a room with your friends hanging out
laughing at a game or screaming at a
game or getting frustrated or whatever
it is I just want to feel like it's more
real and I want to do it more often than
I've been doing in the past because what
I imagine is I'm gonna livestream for
about two hours everyday starting about
10:00 a.m. go until noon and then just
hanging out with you because I don't
know that's what it's always been about
and that's what I've always loved about
it I never want to let that go
and that's very important to me first
I'm gonna go get some Cracker Barrell so
anyway guys just my thoughts for now how
she can do it a bunch
ah sweet scratch
Oh righty then anyway that was weird but
bad news
somehow we haven't made up any time at
all it's now 928 it still says we're
gonna get there at 10:56 but I haven't
thought if I call them
and ask politely
baby number one maybe they're open later
than I think they're and number two
maybe there are a fan and the
what are you gonna try hi my name is
Mark
I was just wondering what's the latest
you can place it to go order I gotcha I
would need to be there exactly at 10 so
if I was say 45 minutes away heaven was
gonna probably get there 10:15 that's
not gonna work okay alright well thank
you very much
that is always a possibility tomorrow is
always another day yeah okay thank thank
you bye bye
Siri navigate to the nearest cliff
a peaceful death
[Music]
we can get another
Wow can't believe we finally did it it's
been like two weeks since the last time
I had Cracker Barrel I've never gone
that long between barrel runs before but
there's been a lot of fun it's such a
cool experience to be able to do this
with you so I'm glad you were along for
the ride
thanks so much and I do want to do more
I got a whole bunch of ideas for more
creative stuff not the going to get
Cracker Barrel in a van and you buy for
the exclusive chance to go get Cracker
Barrel isn't incredibly original but you
know I got a lot of other ideas that I
want to do a lot of fun stuff that I
want to try and that doesn't mean that I
let go of anything else that I've done
before like it I still love playing
video games that still up making
sketches I still love doing stuff but I
always want to make videos that I'm
happy with and I always want to make
things that I'm proud of and and I want
to make things that that are always
worth your time you know even if there
is something as simple as going
sometimes the littlest things can mean
the most and that's it thank you so much
for watching and let me know what
adventure we should take next
and as always bye-bye